Electric cars and plug-in hybrids are all
the rage at the moment.
But the Toyota Prius -- the grandfather of
them all -- has been out on the road for around
20 years now.
The Japanese carmaker has regularly updated
the technology of course.
The current model being sold in showrooms
is the vehicle's fourth generation.
Car tester Ines Petri explains that the latest
Prius comes in a full hybrid or plug-in version.
The latter is more for people who can run
a cable to the car at home.
In the full hybrid, on the other hand, batteries
are charged by the gasoline engine out on
the road -- or by recovering energy during
braking and engine braking, she says.
Ines is taking out the full-hybrid, self-charging
variant of the Prius.
Its power is provided either by a 1-point-8-liter
gasoline engine and an electric motor that can also work
independently of its internal combustion counterpart.
A secondary electric motor converts power
from the gas engine into electrical energy
stored in the batteries.
Altogether, the system puts out 90 kilowatts
of power.
The Prius can hit 100 kilometers an hour from
a standstill in 10-point-6 seconds and has
a top speed of 180.
Toyota says it burns just 3-point-3 liters
of fuel per hundred kilometers.
Ines says that over the years, Toyota has
managed to make the hybrid feel more and more
like a standard internal combustion engine
car.
Drivers can choose different driving modes...
among them the environmentally friendly Eco-Mode,
a Normal mode and a Power mode for when you
want a little more juice.
The latter really gives the car a lot of zip.
There's also a purely electric mode for when
the car is travelling at low speeds.
However, the full hybrid only manages that
trick for around two kilometers.
And that's the decisive difference between
it and the plug-in version.
The plug-in has larger batteries that give
it a range of about 50 kilometers.
This variant is also 11 centimeters longer.
But because the technology takes up more space,
Prius plug-ins have 140 liters less volume
in the trunk.
A two-part hatch has also been a character
trait in the model for the last two generations.
The interior is a study in contrasts and anything
but boring.
The dashboard display is narrow and sleek.
A lot of the important data appears on a high-tech
central console.
The shifter also has a futuristic look and
feel.
All these polished surfaces contribute to
the car's modern look, says Ines.
But they can also start to look dusty pretty
quickly.
That's why she would recommend always carrying
a featherduster on board.
Just a swipe and everything gleams again.
The displays also make a very modern impression.
Especially the one up here on the dashboard,
which lets you know what's going on in the
car all the time.
Another modern touch -- an induction plate
for charging your smartphone without having
to plug it in.
The most antiquated feature is the parking
brake in the footwell.
Ines says electric and plug-in hybrid cars
are really taking off.
But for her, a full hybrid vehicle like this
one still has a place, even though its range
is much more restricted than a plug-in.
That's because not everyone has access to
charging cables at home...or just doesn't
want to bother with cables all the time.
In general, she thinks, a key moment for the
sector will come when the batteries can be
charged through induction -- and you can dispense
with cables altogether.